là on essaie à la sablière key account
en ville
nous on s'est installés juste là à
chartres là on à châteaudun a line
beaulieu et toutes les écuries de
châteaudun juste derrière on a ce nom et
puis juste là bas on les aperçoit fait
le poney club de st près avec nathalie
roger et chez les beaucerons
l'organisation est rodée apéro en commun
soirées à thème
il y a une vie après le cheval les
cavaliers viennent avec leur famille
c'est pratique quand il s'agit d'assurer
l'intendance à les salades pour tout le
monde et vous servez vous fait passer en
suit le club avec nos enfants et donc on
prépare tous les menus avant d' avance
si on a un menu des listes on fait les
courses avant et après maman après c'est
que dieu que du bonheur
place à la compétition pour la jeune
ingrid dominique le coach prodigue les
derniers conseils restés stables soit
patiente alors apte et les articles
le résultat n'importe peu voilà le tout
c'est vraiment de se faire plaisir là
est d'arriver dans un état d'esprit de
clubs et de petites fêtes à l'intérieur
du club pour qu'on pour qu'on puisse
savoir le plaisir d'être là et verre
ensemble un parcours un peu chaotique
quelques bars au sol mais l'essentiel
est ailleurs
tellement 1er au 6 mai bombes 2 bal
principal secteur
c'est que je suis parti j'ai participé
voilà on est déjà assez déjà c'est déjà
le but et voilà retour au campement une
autre cavalière et loire a décroché le
titre dans sa catégorie et tout le monde
est là pour l'applaudir oublier les
rivalités entre clubs participent et
s'amuser c'est ça l'esprit la motte